okay so the new trailer for Spider-Man
across the spiderverse has just dropped
and in this video we're going to be
breaking down the new characters Easter
eggs hidden details and also giving our
reaction to the new look we also know a
lot more about the movie than we did
when we first covered it back in
December last year and in this video
we're gonna be talking about it all now
into the spider-verse ended with Miles
and his bed looking up and at this point
Gwen opened a portal above him the first
luck had him slightly older and they've
actually added in some extra clothes
here to show that it isn't exactly the
same moment that we last ended on
therefore Gwen might have visited him
from time to time or they could just be
Reckoning the whole thing and being like
forget about that ending and the first
movie had the multiversal travel
affecting those that moved across it and
because of this they started to glitch
out however the post-credit scenes show
that Spider-Man 2099 had developed a
device that allowed one to stabilize
When In Another Universe known as
miguelo horror I think he's gonna be the
driving force of the film that pulls all
the characters to together from across
the spider-verse hey now if you look
closely at Gwen's wrist you can see that
she's wearing something on it which will
likely stop her glitching out and this
is something we see in the other
Spider-Man throughout the teaser in the
first look we learned that Miles had
been grounded but as Spider-Man hadn't
he was allowed to go out his room now
this was coupled with him traveling
across the Multiverse into alternate
realities the first one we had confirmed
was Spider-Man India who appeared in the
spite of a storyline in the comics that
this movie is potentially based on and
that should be a fully up to speed and
if you enjoy the video please hit the
thumbs up button and don't forget to
subscribe a breakdown take this every
day with that and try out the way huge
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into the across the spider-verse
trailer
now we start off with the Sony logo
before transitioning into the Columbia
one if you slow the trailer down to 0.25
speed then you can see this change to an
animation style similar to the old
Archie comics from here we joined
miles's mother talking to him on a
rooftop as he looks over the city's
similar to shots from into the
spider-verse she talks about how she
feels she lost her son and that he's not
the child she knew now this is very
important and it's something that often
shows up as a character trait in every
single Spider-Man in order to protect
the ones they love Spider-Man has to
stay distant and thus he seems like he's
not really a part of their lives anymore
this was seen at the end of the first
Remy movie when Peter turned MJ down and
it's a sacrifice that all the characters
have to go through now at this point we
get several shots of the last film this
includes miles buying the costume from
Stan Lee him trying it on him Swinging
with PW Parker after robbing the
computer from the alchemax labs riding
with Gwen on the bus with Peter B Parker
in the back and him feeling like he
doesn't measure up to being Spider-Man
in the spider cave however this is is
shut down by the leap of faith moment
that defined his life this was when he
became Spider-Man and we then see him
leaping through the streets and never
before seen footage he shoots out
several webs and this stops a
taxi-hitting pedestrians which is
similar how Andrew Garfield's versions
stopped that car in the electro Times
Square fight we then see him snatching a
hot dog and if you slow down the footage
you can actually see the sound effect of
this saying take you up some money to
the guy's chest and then we cut to his
dad saying that he loves him now at this
point we see a slight change up in
miles's room with more things being
added he's also now wearing a basketball
jersey with a number 42 on it 42 was a
number that constantly appeared in the
first movie at several points and this
brings a lot with it not only is this
the meaning of everything but it's also
the number that Jackie Robinson wore
Jackie was the first black athlete to
play Major League Baseball and the first
movie had his number throughout as an
odd to him by his head we can also catch
the cover of Amazing Fantasy 15 which
was the first appearance of your boy
Spider-Man man Gwen calls out to him and
she's now wearing a pink jacket whereas
in the first look she wasn't because I
watched she about 500 times a spider
Gwen coming back brings a lot more with
it this time around we know we'll be
traveling to her world and also meeting
a father Captain Stacy who'll be voiced
by Shea Wiggum Captain Stacy of course
died in the 616 but we saw how the first
spider-verse film changed things up from
the breadcrumbs a backstory we got from
Gwen it was her Peter that passed away
and on his body we could catch lizard
scales meaning that he became the
villain instead of Kirk Connors so her
father being alive makes sense too and
I'm interested to see what dynamic he
brings to the movie now hexagonal
portals are something that have popped
up throughout a lot of MC projects with
them also showing up here in the MCU
they use his jump points in space and
hexagons in general also showed up a lot
in one division there they signified
Wonder's hex reality and for this movie
they're also going to be used as travel
points between realities we did see
characters traveling across the
Multiverse in the first film but it was
absent of these hexagonal shapes
therefore I think that this movie will
have the hexagons sort of being like
train tracks and that they take you from
one predetermined destination rather
than just flinging you out anywhere
that's also how they work in space with
them directing people instead of just
throwing them into a black hole sort of
shows how it's all connected but I might
be reading into that too much as
hexagons in general are just interesting
shapes that will stack together nicely
but this is a deep dive and it's a good
deal well it's an alright Deep dive but
you're still a [ __ ] chump now across
the spider verse there's lots of
different characters jumping into
alternate realities across the
spiderverse you might have guessed it
the internet's actually quite similar
and did you know that in different
countries that actually exist different
rules around what you can view and see
for example a lot of my us heads don't
know but in England on Disney plus we
have a whole section called star that
has lots of different programs that you
can't get in the US however there is a
way and that comes with nordvpn I really
love node VPN I was so happy when they
hit me up because I've been using them
for over two years now and they're an
incredible VPN provider not even lying
every time I go on my laptop or on my TV
or my fire stick I'll end up using them
because they provide so much access to
so much stuff that I wouldn't get
otherwise they're very easy to use and
you can connect with one click or enable
auto connect for zero click protection
they've got over 5200 servers in 59
countries that all come with amazing
speed it's actually being confirmed by
the speed tests and nordvpn is the
fastest VPN out there it's available on
every major platform such as Windows
Android iOS Mac OS and even Linux now if
you're getting a VPN obviously security
is probably on your mind as well and not
have that covered they've got Advanced
anti-malware features that are the next
step in protecting the user and offering
a safer and smoother online experience a
threat production also stops web
trackers and intrusive ads when you
download a file a threat protection
automatically scans it so you don't have
to worry about malware with these
Advanced tools as well nordvpn is more
than just a VPN it's now a cyber
security tool so with the security
handle you can just sit back and relax
and watch your favorite movies and TV
shows without worrying if you're getting
spied on get four months free on a
two-year plan at nordvpn.com heavy
spoilers it's risk-free and nordvpn have
a 30 day money back guarantee so you're
in safe hands I use it all my team use
it we absolutely love it so make sure
you check it out thanks at this point
they end up in what appears to be the
Nexus where all Spider-Man will be
gathered there's a lot going on here and
when I saw mate I was like
it's gonna be a long night tonight
however we want to point out all the
spider people here so sit tight and shut
the [ __ ] up now the people standing
behind the pair I'll probably end up
covering as we pull out but they're all
pretty generic except for the PS4
looking one who I'll talk more about in
just a bit this isn't the PS4 Spider-Man
just a similar suit but yeah we'll talk
more about the main one in just a bit
now when we go back we can see two
spider women on the left with one
wearing the normal suit and another
wearing what's either the negative one
or the armor one next is the bulletproof
suit which you'll likely know from the
PS4 game alongside this is a bigger
Spider-Man wearing a similar costume to
the armor suit and to the right of him
is the Don PS4 Spider-Man you might
remember that his suit was actually
shown in the spider Cape collection back
in the first film but this movie will
see someone actually wearing it I'm
really hoping that this connects him
with the next game and with the Miles
Morales one having a spider-verse suit
and that it looks like they could be
tying it all together the new game is
coming up very soon too and our room is
that we might be getting a trailer very
shortly that builds off the back of this
anyway if you're one of the 15 people
that didn't play that game I want a
quick rundown they basically picked up
with Peter Parker in the midst of his
career as he rolled off the back of
having just taken down the Kingpin his
Aunt May was also running Feast
alongside her partner Martin Lee turns
out Lee was actually a villain that had
risen up in the power vacuum left behind
by Fisk and under the name Mr negative
he did whatever he could to destroy man
Norman Osborne's re-election campaign
after attacking an event at Jefferson
Davis was killed and Peter became
somewhat of a mentor to miles miles
eventually was bitten by a genetically
engineered spider that was created by
Osborne which gave him his own spider
abilities now Peter was also working
with Dr Otto Octavius to create a new
form of prosthetic limb this ended up
taking over his body and thus he became
a Doctor Octopus spoiler alert
now Peter managed to take both forces
down but unfortunately ant May was
killed during this there's tons of other
stuff like villains escaping from the
raft and so on but I'll be here all day
if I go through that and and those are
the main points that you need to know
about Spider-Man PS4 which isn't really
his name either way seeing him in the
film is going to be a major addition and
it looks like he sort of gained his own
kid his own miles if you will which is a
reflection of PW Parker and miles's
relationship the person's wearing a
black and red costume and it looks very
similar to The Superior Spider-Man one
this is when dark Arc mind swapped with
Peter and he became the Webhead slowly
he was turned good by taking on the role
and it's so cool seeing them both here
once we pull out we get what I believe
is the rubber suit used to fight Electro
and next to this is the Civil War suit
this was designed by Tony Stark for the
Civil War comic and it's what he used
when he sided with him he ended up
giving it up once he switched sides and
it's such a cool suit that I'm glad to
see here now as we pull further out to
the left we can see spider pig hey
having that
no now this is spider cop who comes from
the comics if you play the PS4
Spider-Man game though you'll know that
when he's chatting to Yuri that the wall
crawler refers to himself as Spider cop
but the real character will be popping
up in this film he's a seasoned vet of
the NYPD that was given spider powers in
the comics he was actually recruited by
spider-gwen to help in the spite of her
storyline now to the right of him we can
also see what a sort of Steampunk
Spider-Man though I'm not exactly sure
who this is a lot of people in this shot
are just kind of variations that aren't
really from the comics and if they are
then yeah you know to drop it below I
don't know every single version of
Spider-Man ever so he probably picked
the wrong video to watch now as we go
further out we do start to see more and
more recognizable ones the one with the
bag on the head is a nod to end Spidey
joined the Fantastic Four and handed on
this in order to hide his identity love
the art style of this and they have him
in his 60s pop art animation to
reference the iraji debut in the top
right we also have spider werewolf which
no prices because guessing which version
of Spider-Man that is now Scarlet Spider
will be featuring the film too this
often overlooked character has kind of
been ostracized but he originates from
the clone saga that dominated comics in
the 90s during that time Publishers were
replacing their main Heroes with other
versions and just in the same way that
Batman was replaced by Jean-Paul Valley
Peter Parker was pushed out too created
by the Jackal using Peter's DNA it was
thought that the Clone died alongside
his creator back in the 70s however it
turned out that he survived and
realizing that he was a clone he decided
to live in Exile away from New York
using his uncle's first name and ant
May's maiden name he was inspired to
become his own person that was sort of
like a Drifter moving from town to town
and helping out people his spider Sensei
did several police investigations and he
fell in love with a woman called Janine
who too was on the Run being racked with
guilt though she ended her own life and
Ben became a janitor at Portland high
school he saved a woman from some home
Invaders and was once more inspired to
use his great powers to take on great
responsibilities eventually he went back
to New York and confronted Peter and
helped him get through some really bad
times he worked alongside Spider-Man as
the Scarlet Spider and eventually he
became the main one after it seemed
clear that Peter was the Clone and not
Ben drove Peter almost insane and though
they kept their names he ended up
leaving the position of course this was
eventually all revealed to be untrue and
Peter Parker took the role back as the
main one but there was a time where Ben
was your number one now from here we cut
back to Gwen and miles and see Peter B
Parker the boy the Don daughter never
late with the ren King who is back for
the movie obviously he was one of the
big parts that made the first movie as
successful as it was and there was never
any doubt that he was going to be back
for a sequel when we last left him he
was going to his MJ to fix their
relationship and it looks like it's good
news being a dad myself I instantly
recognized that carrier on the front
looks like my man is now a father
congratulations now hit the thumbs up
button at this point we get the shot of
miles and Gwen sitting upside down on a
Ledge this has been used in a lot of the
promotional material and it's of course
riffing on the shot from the first movie
in which miles Sat by himself
interestingly miles's spider symbol is
the right way up here meaning that he
must be wearing upside down strange but
also Gwen's hair is longer here too
where they're having it in a ponytail
showing roughly how much time has passed
since the first film now from here we
see a motorbike busting through the air
and I believe this is israe's version of
Spider-Woman it's a big departure from
her look in the comics but with this
being the Multiverse they've clearly
changed her up this is a major character
in the Spider-Man lore and she was
introduced all the way back in 1978. for
this story if you want to know Stanley
he actually thought that's some other
comic book company would probably just
do a gender swab of their number one
Webhead if they ever got hold of the
copyright to him so he just came up with
Spider Woman in order to stop this from
happening she was only supposed to
feature in a Marvel Spotlight however
she's done a lot since her creation and
has become a Mainstay in the comics
Marvel Spotlight 32 sold really well and
the company saw her as being more than
someone used to establish a trademark
Marv Wolfman was given an ongoing series
and this allowed him to take the
character and push here to the Forefront
now originally she was a spider that
transformed into a human not however
this was quickly reckoned and she was
said to be a human that just had
memories of being a spider planted into
her by Hydra given the name Jessica Drew
this was a combination of Marv's
daughter's first name and the name of
her favorite detective Nancy Drew and
Jessica can fly climb walls and
basically do a lot of what a spider can
if you've played the Miles Morales
Spider-Man game then you'll also be
familiar with his Venom energy blast
switch Jessica herself can do she also
has pheromones which you can use to
manipulate emotions now her origin
stories had several records to it but
the current one that's seen as the Canon
is that her mother was struck with a
beam of radiation when she was pregnant
with Jess this contains several
different spider dnas and you bloody
guessed it Jessica was born with spider
powers that's more the current
understanding of her though like I said
depending on what you read you might get
something different like a lot of comic
book characters back then she had a slow
decline over the years and the Riders
actually killed her off in her 50th
issue she kind of faded Into Obscurity
but she was brought back in a big bad
way during the 2005 New Avengers run she
also played a big part in secret
Invasion when a scroll masqueraded as
her though we know she won't be popping
up in the Disney plus adaptation still
though great seeing her in this and it's
one of my favorite appearances in the
trailer now you might also notice who
she's attacking and this is actually the
vulture whereas in the classic
Incarnation he was Adrian tombs they are
changing things a lot up for the movie
now tombs in the comics is mostly shown
as an old guy he uses a vulture costume
to commit robberies but the movie though
he will be voiced by Joe matakon and
will be a renaissance inspired criminal
at has an Italian accent
probably a bit offensive that to some
people now when you get when you get an
Italian actors yeah you should have just
got Chris Pratt to voice that if you
wanted Italian but I'm guessing this guy
he's gonna be pretty good as well big
change up for the vulture obviously we
saw him done classically by Michael
Keaton and it is gonna be interesting to
see what he brings to the movie now
Charles Murphy posted some of the first
story details for the movie yesterday on
his website Murphy's Multiverse we'll
talk about what he said on the spot
later on but we have a pretty good idea
what the film will be about based off
this new teaser and his report it says
after reuniting with Gwen Stacy
Brooklyn's full-time friendly
neighborhood Spider-Man is catapulted
across the Multiverse where he
encounters a team of spider people
charged with protecting its very
existence but when the heroes Clash on
how to handle a new threat miles finds
himself pitted against you the spiders I
must redefine what it means to be a hero
so he can save the people he loves most
now who this new thread is is likely the
spot however there are the big villains
that could be popping up later on now
he's going to be clashing heads with
Miguel O'Hara AKA Spider-Man 2099 O'Hara
is half Irish and half Mexican and he is
a Spider-Man of the futuristic Nueva
York the majority of the city I hope I
pronounced that right and the majority
of this city is controlled by the
alcamex corporation which was also the
science division that Kingpin ran in the
first spider-verse film as a young adult
ahara got a job working for them which
is where he was pressured into running a
test to imprint genetic codes on the
humans the test subject died and racked
with guilt Miguel ended up going to his
boss Tyler Stone who gave him a drink
this was laced with a futuristic drug
called Rapture that bonded itself to
someone's blood and gave them intense
hallucinations in order to rid himself
of this Miguel ran the test on himself
which is when his DNA was spliced with
that of his spiders he gained several
abilities including the usual spider
powers such as increased strength speed
and also reflexes is however Miguel can
also move so fast that he actually
leaves behind the decoy in addition to
this he can communicate with people
telepathically and he carries elongated
fans that can secrete a paralyzing toxin
he has razor sharp clothes too which we
see pop out and he looks way bulkier
than the design that we've seen on him
previously when we catch him he's
looking over a video of his daughter and
the name ryella can be seen up top
clearly a note to Riley which as we
mentioned was ant May's maiden name now
though I don't think he's in the trailer
we know that spider Punk will be in the
film and they'll be voiced by Daniel
kaluya the character was originally
ripping on spider UK but he's kind of
grown into his own entity and thing
coming from Earth 138 he was revealed to
be Herbert Brown who was a homeless
teenager that was transformed due to
Norman Osborne dumping some toxic waste
he's a punk rocker that carries his
guitar with him almost wherever he goes
and in the comics it's what he used to
smash Norman Osborne's head in like it
was that like button in the spider-verse
storyline he was recruited by Superior
Spider-Man to join the Spider-Man and I
can't wait to see what he's like in the
film especially with the art style I
could do with them lots of crazy Punk
stuff they can do with this punk you
goddamn chump see you chump now there's
a massive scene where lots of different
characters jump miles and if you look
closely you can see one with six arms
that wraps themselves around him this is
similar to the mutated Spider-Man from
the comics in TV show and of course the
spiders in general have six arms and two
legs equaling a limbs say that now I
just love this shot of them all swinging
towards him and we even see a slightly
chubby one gliding in now Japanese
Spider-Man is also going to be featuring
the film as well he pulls from the live
action TV show universe created in 1978
and though often overlooked this
live-action adaptation massively helped
to push the character's popularity
worldwide his origin story is really
removed from the typical Spider-Man
stuff and originally he was a motorcycle
racer called takuya UFO called the
Marvel I fell to Earth and after tuning
inside of it he was injected with blood
from planet spider which gave him his
abilities as always aliens and clicking
together his bracelets activates his
costume he can also shoot web lines from
them and so you can pop up yeah it's a
nice thing for the fans who have watched
a couple of episodes of that show if
you've sat through the whole thing
congratulations because you're better
than me yeah and I'm sure you're gonna
love this just as much as I am now 2099
rushes towards him and in slow-mo you
can see him enlarging his gauntlets as
he charges towards him such a cool shot
but he's clearly barking up the wrong
tree we actually know that the villain
in the movie is gonna be the spot and
that he'll also be the bad guy in the
sequel beyond the spider-verse Ken
Powers is directing the film and over
the last couple of weeks he's had a
number of big interviews with some big
Outlets when discussing the movie with
total film he confirmed that the
character will be a villain across both
films whereas the first movie dealt with
the Kingpin this more multiversal one
will be bringing him into it to add to
the idea that the further out you get
the more far the villains do as well
it's gonna be such a cool addition for
the movie and in the comics Jonathan own
was a highly decorated graduate of MIT
that was even roommates with Quentin
Beck a divorced dad he started working
for the Kingpin and he was tasked with
discovering how the Clark's Powers
worked the clerk can create portals in
himself and Kingpin wanted to duplicate
his power for his own personal gains now
due to his origin story he may be linked
in with the first film and there's the
potential that he helped Kingpin
Builders collided back in that movie
either way Jonathan succeeded in his
research and after creating a portal one
night he stepped into it which is where
he was taken to the cloak's dark
dimension it's not to be confused with
the other doctor mentioned and here he
began to master the realm and looked
about it earlier the portals for the
place where he just come from after
swimming through the landscape for some
time he was able to return home and make
it back to the kitchen where he'd opened
up the dimension now Upon returning to
the 616 his body had undergone a major
transformation and he was littered with
the portals that we see on him now when
he was in the dark dimension the other
portals had attached themselves to his
skin like leeches and they basically
made him a walking Wormhole he's going
to be littering the landscape with black
holes which are slowly gonna start
sucking things into them now in the
comics he's pretty much a joke character
that's not really a big bad which is why
I was really surprised that he was
chosen for being such a major threat
however after thinking about it there's
so many really cool things that they can
do with him especially from an animation
point of view watching him get hit in a
portal and their fist popping up
somewhere else is such a cool thing that
they can do the battles will become Next
Level by having him in the movie I love
this shot where we see miles kicking the
spot in the chest and then it hits Gwen
who's station behind them if you look at
his hands you can also see that he's
throwing spots out too if you've ever
watched the 4K into the spider-verse on
an OLED then you'll know there's bits
where the full screen goes completely
black and it has these little bits of
color I'd love to see something like
that with the dark dimension too and
having characters pop in and out of it
will be absolutely incredible just shows
how the villain can use the heroes to
fight each other I'm getting hyped up to
watch some insane fights playing out
anyway we end with everyone on Miles and
a what a banger of a teaser there's so
many different animation styles that are
gonna feature in this film and whereas
the first movie just had the one this
will have six different styles across
the entire thing the creative team have
said this is to wow the audience every
time we enter a new universe the style
will also help reflect the world in
characters and it's gonna add so much
more to the movie for example Gwen's
home will be more impressionistic like a
watercolor painting and it'll bring a
new dimension to the movies and the
animation style overall into the
spider-verse of course when an Oscar and
by the looks of this new teaser I can
easily see this securing one too looks
like they've knocked it out of the park
and they're going to be having so many
different Spider-Man in it that it's
gonna make the first one look like they
were just having a quiet gathering
around your mates on a Monday night Lord
and Miller said there's gonna be 240k
characters in the movie and this is
going to be a crazy celebration of every
version we've had so far the new look
feels like it's barely scratching the
surface but it's packed with so much
that I can't wait to see what the final
release is like great trailer and
obviously let me know your thoughts on
it below if you are any competition
right now and giving away three copies
of House of the Dragon season one on the
15th of December and all you have to do
to be on the chance of winning is like
the video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the trailer
we pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now save
that to you then message me on Twitter
at heavy spoilers if you want something
else to watch then make sure you check
out our breakdown of the boys spin-off
show gen V which is on screen right now
lots of cool Easter eggs and links back
to the main Series so definitely head
over there right after this by the way
thanks for sticking through the video
I've been Paul I'll see you next time
take care peace